more than a hundred days into the war in
ukraine and the fighting is intensifying
in the east
[Music]
far from the front lines the conflict
impacting the global food supply
especially in africa which imports 40
percent of its grain from russia and
ukraine
the chair of the african union traveling
to sochi to help get deliveries back on
track
i spoke to the european council and i
told them yes there is a war the crisis
but there's also sanctions we should
work together on resolving these two
problems and make sure that everything
concerning food and grain supplies is
outside the sanctions
his meeting president putin ended with a
promise to ease the export of grain from
russian-controlled ports
putin blaming the west for using moscow
as a scapegoat
of course now we see an attempt to shift
responsibility for the global food
crisis to russia this attempt as our
people like to say is an attempt to
shift from a sick head to a healthy one
food prices have shut up across africa
since russia invaded ukraine with fears
of famine and the u.n warning of mass
migration if food doesn't reach african
shores fast
russia has played a hunger game
recently to put blame
on ukraine and others for blocking
ukrainian food experts
so basically they are saying that
the imminent hunger in africa and
elsewhere will become soon because of
the western sanctions on russia and not
because of russia's invasion of ukraine
and blocking of ukrainian force
but despite today's pledge it remains
unclear when those ports will be able to
release the supplies africa and the
world so desperately
needs jillian wolf al jazeera